today on the matt welsh show we'll
discuss the very funny but also
instructive story of a woman who left
america because of its violence and
racism
and moved instead to mexico a country
that is of course far worse than america
in every category and by every measure
also five headlines including joe biden
continuing to fall apart on camera
and uh supposedly the supposedly surging
q anon movement that the media is
talking a lot about why are they talking
so much about q anon we'll talk about
that and
in our daily cancellation i'll cancel
ryan reynolds for being the latest
celebrity to issue a groveling
and ridiculous apology all of that on
the way but first the show today is
brought to you by policy genius you know
even with everything going on it's still
possible to buy life insurance not just
possible but it's something that you
you need to do you should do it's still
easy to shop for life insurance right
now and if you have a loved one
and you live you have loved ones or or
anyone depending on you
for you and your income you probably
should
shop for life insurance right now you
could save 1500
or more a year by using policy genius to
compare life insurance policies
when you're shopping for a policy that
could last for a decade or more
those savings really start to add up
what is policy genius well it's an
insurance marketplace it's built and
backed by a team of industry experts
and it's very simple here's how it works
we'll go through the steps step one head
to policygenius.com in minutes you can
work out how much coverage you need you
can compare quotes from top insurers to
find your best
price step two just apply for your
lowest price and then step three
the pulse of genus team will handle all
the paperwork and all the red tapes you
only have to worry about
step three you don't have to worry about
all you got is step one and two just go
to the site
find the lowest price and boom it's as
easy as that policy genius works for you
not the insurance company so
if you hit any speed bumps during the
application process uh
they'll take care of everything look
shopping for life insurance can be
pretty stressful
no doubt about it i've been through it
myself but policy genius
makes it easy that's what they're there
to do so if you need life insurance head
to
policygenius.com right now to get
started you could save
1500 or more a year by comparing quotes
on their marketplace it's as simple as
that policy genius
when it comes to insurance it's nice to
get it
right policygenius.com okay
so an article uh published this week on
cnn is worth a closer inspection for two
very excellent reasons first of all it's
unintentionally hilarious
second it reveals the total incoherence
and rampant
self-contradiction of the america is
racist and evil crowd
um the piece titled she packed her bags
quit her job
in law enforcement and moved to mexico
after george george floyd's death
that's the title tells the story of a
woman named uh
demeteria or dimitri demetria brown who
as the title suggests fled alleged uh
systemic persecution in america and
sought refuge in the peaceful utopia of
the
second most violent country on earth
right behind syria by the way
let's read a little bit from this
article it says
on june 1st a week after floyd's death
brown quit her job as a detention
officer for the los angeles county
probation department
in the midst of the global coronavirus
pandemic she sold her house stuffed her
belongings into 13 duffel bags
and uh relocated to puerto
vallarta on the mexico on mexico's
pacific
coast brown 42 is one of many
african-americans leaving the united
states
permanently for many reasons including
racism and fear of police brutality
her flight landed in her new hometown on
june 25th a month
to the day that uh floyd died where that
informed that a number of black
americans have chosen to engage in what
is apparently by some people being
called blacksid
and the article goes on from there a
little bit more from cnn it says while
there are no official statistics on how
many uh
how many have left the country black
people have turned to social media
to get insight from those who've
relocated especially to african and
caribbean nations
where some say they feel safer as part
of the
majority majority for brown following
her heart
and living without fear of racism keep
that in mind
meant moving to the resort town 1200
miles from the city she'd worked
as a detention officer since 2004.
um it also says that she let's say she
visited mexico several times before she
decided to relocate to the nation
which the state department says is home
to 1.5 million u.s citizens
that number includes u.s born children
who've returned to their mexican parents
american retirees and digital nomads
continues she calls the move the best
decision she's ever
made and it says while mexico is not
perfect
and has its own problems she says she's
never encountered any racism in the
tourist destination made famous by the
1960s film
the knight of the iguana now
we're also told that brown is a life
coach now uh and a travel blogger
and i admit i i don't know much about
the life coaching business
but i would highly recommend that if you
pay someone to coach you through life
and their coaching tip is
is is is to move to a crime-ridden third
world country where severed heads
litter the streets ask for your money
back
that's just that's the advice i would
give all right now granted
brown because she is so dedicated to
equality and social justice
has chosen to live in a resort town
where you know rich people go
to be pampered by impoverished locals
that's how that's how socially aware she
is
and that should afford her some measure
of insulation and protection from the
horrors that are a daily part of life
for many mexicans
but that doesn't change the fact that
mexico is
by every conceivable measure
considerably worse
than the united states let's go through
some of those measures
shall we mexico's murder rate is seven
times higher
than the u.s police corruption is so bad
that entire police forces are arrested
for being on the payroll of the drug
cartels what about racism
well funny enough cnn has itself
reported
that racism in mexico quote hides in
plain sight and that quote
the best highest paying jobs uh the most
important jobs in
mexico often seem to go to those who in
addition to having the best education
the strongest connections have the
lightest skin
that's what cnn told us in an article
what about treatment of immigrants usa
today reports that immigrants in mexico
are treated quote
much worse than they are in quote any
other country
someone who moves to mexico especially
from countries to the south
faces a significant chance of being
kidnapped by a cartel
robbed or extorted by police or other
government officials
mexico is indeed far tougher both in
legal and illegal ways
on immigrants and refugees and if brown
thinks that well at least mexico is a
place where income
equality reigns supreme she is again
delusional
the vast majority of the wealth in the
country is concentrated in the hands of
the elites
while nearly half of the population
lives in poverty
by comparison the poverty rate in the
united states is less than 12 percent
it's like
48 or around there in mexico 12
in the united states mexico is less safe
less equitable less tolerant less
progressive
right down the line in every category
though i'm sure it's still night in the
nice in the resort towns i guess
and and maybe pretty there there's
pretty views provided you don't travel
too far outside of them
and find yourself getting robbed at
gunpoint by a federal rally or
kidnapped and beheaded by a cartel but
this is as i said
instructive those who complain about all
of the alleged systemic problems in
america
tend to have a childishly simplistic if
not hallucinatory view of the issues in
question and the world at large
you know they look through a cartoon
lens and believe
despite a total lack of evidence or
logical reasoning that america is
uniquely racist
uniquely unjust uniquely evil the
absurdity of this perspective becomes
all the more obvious when they act on it
by
leaving and seeking shelter on some
other country's shores
because the fact is that wherever they
choose especially if they choose mexico
but the same holds true almost anywhere
else
they will end up somewhere that has
quite a bit more
of whatever it was they were trying to
escape in fact
they may well find themselves in a place
where the cartoon
in their head has come to life
police in america are not prowling the
streets robbing and murdering innocent
people for no reason despite what blm
tells us it's not happening
it is not happening police in mexico
actually are doing that people like
brown you know invent problems that
don't exist in america and then move to
countries
where they really do exist
and that is that is the great irony here
so you know the response to america
haters
for a long time from the other side has
been hey if you don't like it
get out um
and the interesting thing is that i
guess now according to cnn some of the
american haters are saying okay fine we
will
but it's only proving the point of the
other side because they get out and go
to a place
that's way way worse because as it turns
out
you know the united states of america is
certainly not a perfect country by any
means
there are changes to be made there are
things to
improve there always will be that
because countries are
human institutions and we are a fallen
species and that's just the way it's
going to be
so you keep working to make it better
but in spite of all that
america is uh
in a much better position and a much
better state
again by almost any measure when
compared to
nearly every other country on earth
and by the way that's especially the
case
especially the case when it comes to
issues like racial tolerance
racial tolerance in many other countries
um
especially non-western countries isn't
even
a concept it's not it's not even
something that is it it's it's it's
there is no real concern for it that it
isn't even discussed
on an aspirational level
meanwhile the united states of america
being the most diverse country on earth
with 330 million people
of many different races and backgrounds
and ethnicities all
living together i mean if you if you
tried that experiment
in many other countries it would be a
total unmitigated
disaster and
here it works better than it would work
anywhere else
and that's just the simple fact of the
matter let's move on to our five
headlines
well these are always fun joe biden
was interviewed by i believe yahoo news
and was asked
whether he would take a cognitive test
and his answer you might say proves
why he needs one watch have you taken
a cognitive no i haven't taken the test
why the hell would i take a test
come on man that's like saying you
before you got in this program if you
take a test where you're taking cocaine
or not what do you think huh
are you a job what do you say to
president trump
who brags about his test and makes your
mental state
an issue for voters well
if he can't figure out the difference
between an elephant and a lion
i don't know what the hell he's talking
about did you watch that look come on
man i i know you're trying to goad me
but i mean i'm so forward
forward-looking to have
an opportunity to sit with the president
or stand with the president and debates
there can be plenty of time and by the
way as i joke with them you know
i i shouldn't say i'm going to say
something i don't i i probably shouldn't
say
anyway i am uh i am very
willing to let the american public judge
my physical mental fil
my physical as well as my mental fitness
oh
joe joe jojo that that you know i'm at
the point now where i actually am
rooting for joe during these interviews
i really
am i i don't i don't say that ironically
i really want him to get through it and
perform well in the interviews
i don't want him to win the election but
just from the sheer
weight of the of second-hand
embarrassment watching this
i i i i want joe to do well i really am
pulling for him
um though i watching this i'm not really
sure if it's
if dementia is the problem versus
drunkenness
because he really came off like a like a
drunk guy especially in the first part
of that interview come on man
come on man that would be like me asking
you
you were taking cocaine come on man
um it's uh it's
it's bad it's bad news and this is this
is in
here's the difference between joe biden
and donald trump we played that
interview yesterday
uh of of donald trump axios and
it was i mean unless you
have completely sacrificed your brain to
partisanship there's no denying that
that
interview was a disaster for donald
trump but um
and he did stammer around around like he
tends to do and it was relatively
incoherent
but it's it's not incoherent in exactly
the same way there's sort of a
difference
where whatever else you say about donald
trump you don't you don't really get the
impression that he's
plunging into senility even though he's
not much younger than
than joe biden you don't you don't get
that impression for with his
incoherence and his eccentricity shall
we say it's just that's who he is that's
how
that's how he's always been that's just
his personality for better or worse
uh with joe biden though it's a very
different sort of thing as i think
most people can tell if they're being
honest number two this was interesting
kindergarten cop
the movie kindergarten cop is now
cancelled
as we go through and belatedly purge all
books shows movies films that
might be offensive to anyone anywhere
for any reason kindergarten cop the
movie where arnold schwarzenegger goes
undercover as a kindergarten teacher
i don't remember why he did what was the
reason for that
was there was it was one of the
kindergarten students was like a
in a drug gang or something he was
trying to i don't remember
um anyway that's now on the chopping
block it was supposed to be shown at a
film festival
in portland and it was pulled after
activists complained about it which
really is not a surprise i mean
it's a film festival in portland
i would already assume that you can't
show any movie in portland
unless it's a movie about a black
transgender polygamist furry
overcoming adversity and learning to
embrace his sexuality um
as far as i know there isn't any such
movie so i guess that's another way of
saying
you can't show any movie in portland
until someone makes that movie
and then that will be the only movie you
can show in portland um
but anyway kindergarten cop got pulled
and get this it's
the reason it got pulled is because it
normalizes
it normalizes the police and it promotes
the idea of having police in school
uh and that's and that's a very terrible
thing apparently we don't want that
i was actually surprised by that because
the moment i saw the headline of
kindergarten cop getting canceled i
assumed they were dumping the movie
because of this scene
boys have a penis girls have a vagina
thanks for the tip what a transphobic
bigot was that kid ever arrested
i hope so probably not though he's
probably still prowling the streets
promoting you know biological science
and thereby
killing people somehow better do
something about that
uh but no that was that was not the
reason that
the movie was canceled all the more
reason to castle of course but
i guess no one no one noticed that and
by the way the reason
no one noticed it is because the people
that are outraged by the movie
clearly have never seen it they just all
they heard is the title kindergarten cop
and that's all they needed to know
number three jerry falwell jr president
of liberty university raised some
eyebrows as they say
when he apparently posted on his
instagram a photo of himself and a young
lady
um on a yacht
in revealing outfits drinking
what would very much appear to be
alcohol uh here's the picture which was
deleted but not before a reporter for
the houston chronicle grabbed it and put
it on twitter
so there you go there um you've got the
young lady unbuttoned
mid mini shorts that the shirt hiked up
fall well too horrifyingly
has his own pants unbuttoned and his
mid-drift showing
and and you know now i looking at this
really feel the urge to burn out my eyes
with a soldering iron
like i said these pictures were deleted
um and from what i've read this was on a
yacht
some kind of or some other kind of boat
was was was apparently a costume part
i'm not sure what costume
this is supposed to be and let me also
point out that falwell is 58 years old
and this really only proves my point
that grown men grown adults should not
wear costumes
certainly not that costume but really
any costume
as as a male once you get over the age
of like
10 uh you're too old for costumes and if
you're a grown man
you're especially too old now
you can say that this isn't a huge deal
and it isn't in the grand scheme of
things
but the problem is that he's the
president
of liberty university and liberty has
very strict guidelines and rules and
according to those rules students could
be fined or even expelled
about five times over for taking that
same picture
that's the issue he violates multiple
rules
that students can not only can be
penalized for
but but are penalized for have been many
times
the alcoholic beverage the outfits
students have faced very harsh penalties
for exactly this kind of thing
and now you know you can you can say
that well it's different because he's
not a student and he's not on campus
okay fine
all right but it is to put it mildly
extremely poor leadership to go
and do not just do but then publicize
yourself doing
the very thing you punish other people
for doing
and you know i've never been a big jerry
falwell fan
to be honest with you and for this
reason this is why
christian frauds who enrich themselves
um there's just something
about those types that i don't like i
don't know maybe it's just me it just
they rubbed me the wrong way
number four uh there's been a lot of
coverage recently of the q
anon conspiracy theories and uh you know
followers of q
and just to be clear a follower of q is
someone who's a follower of random
trolls who post
things on message boards claiming to be
operatives in the government
of course no evidence is ever provided
for any of these claims
and no one asks for it they just follow
along anyway
um that doesn't stop you know with the
conspiracy theories of course that never
stops anyone from latching on
uh but but there's been a lot of
coverage of this recently the media is
trying to
gin up concern about q anon
and this is not to be conspiratorial
myself but i think this is deliberate
the outlet axios which the ones who did
the interview with trump yesterday
they have an article claiming that q
anon is rising
becoming more prominent this is what
they say
among other things they say conspiracy
theories tied to q anon are growing more
popular
there was more than ten times as much
google uh
search interest and q anon in mid-july
than in mid-january according to google
trends data
q anon pages and groups on facebook had
nearly 10 times more likes at the end of
last month than they did in july
or last july there has been a 190
increase in the daily average number of
tweets with popular q and on hashtags
since march
and the article claims parts of the
mainstream republican party have latched
on helping drive its conspiracy
conspiracy theories mainstream 11 q anon
supporters are now 2020
republican congressional nominees uh
that i would have to look up myself
before i would take them at their word
on that one
but either way two points to be made
here
the first as i said i think there's a
deliberate attempt right now by the
media
to make the q anon people more visible
and the obvious reason to do this
is to discredit conservatives and by
extension donald trump
and this is one of the main reasons why
i hate these delusional idiotic
conspiracy theories
because they make us all look like
morons
even though q anon you're in a tiny
fringe it doesn't matter
it's it's embarrassing to all of us the
second point
you know the question always is like why
do people
go in for these kinds of conspiracies
especially one like q
that is so absurdly lacking in any
supporting evidence
whatsoever and i think part of the
reason for that as i've been thinking
about in fact i was reading a book
recently not about q anon but
that mentions this phenomenon called
agent detection
and this is a phenomenon in all sentient
creatures where
you know animal or human assume we tend
to assume
that there's purposeful intention behind
events that may or may not actually have
purposeful intention behind them and
this is this is an evolved capacity and
it's necessary for survival you can see
why so for example a deer in the woods
hears rustling in the leaves and runs
off assuming that the rustling was
caused by a predator
it could have just been the wind but
instinctively the deer assumes intent
assumes there's an intelligent agent
behind the noise
and runs off which you could see how
that would aid in survival we do this
too we hear a bump in the night
you know at your house and immediately
you assume
that there's an intruder right even
though almost always for almost everyone
in almost every case the noise has some
innocuous cause but
it's a survival instinct where the first
thing you think is someone's in the
house
so sometimes people can have what's
called hyperactive agent detection where
they're inclined to find intelligent and
purposeful agency behind every corner
lurking in everything and um i think
that's the problem with conspiracy
theorists
perfect example i mean you could there
are thousands of examples you could use
but perfect example of this not from q
anon but from a different conspiracy
theory
the grotesque and horrendous sandy hook
conspiracy theory
uh the claim that there was no massacre
it was all an act and
the parents of these murdered children
are lying okay
one of the lines of quote evidence for
this
was that an article was posted
after the attack about the attack but
with a timestamp
from before the attack happened the
conspiracy theories with their
hyperactive agent detection jumped in
and presumed
that there was some sinister intention
behind this right some actual willful
reason for it
um now there wasn't time stamps on the
internet are often wrong it's totally
normal there's nothing there's nothing
even very strange about it and besides
what even would be the claim here
that the media was in on the conspiracy
theory and knew that they were going to
do this hoax
and um and then posted an article about
it before they even did it why would
they do that
just it doesn't even even on the
conspiracy theories
theorists theory it doesn't make any
sense at all
but um even so not to mention the whole
idea of having a conspiracy theory that
is that wide-ranging that includes all
these government agencies
and the media and somehow everybody
keeps the secret
no have you ever met a person they're
horrible at keeping secrets the idea
that
hundreds of people in all these
different industries could be involved
in something like that
and never tell anybody is uh is just
another reason why the whole thing is
absurd
but in any event that's what asian
detection is conspiracy theorists see
something that's kind of an anomaly
or a coincidence or an unexplained
detail and they
in their heads extrapolate this entire
wild story
that is purely an invention of their
imagination but they don't realize it
because it's an instinct and for them
it's an instinct gone
gone completely mad
or in any case that is my theory to
explain their theories
number five from from the bbc german car
maker
audi has apologized for an advert
showing a
a little girl eating a banana in front
of a high-performance car
after it drew a torrent of criticism on
social media so
i almost feel like i don't have to read
past that that's just all you need to
know
uh they were it's a girl eating a banana
next to a car
and that people were upset i don't even
there's you can see the picture there i
i can't even quite imagine
you have to be pretty creative speaking
of agency detection it'd be pretty
creative to find a way to be
it wouldn't occur to me to be offended
by that and
that's the one thing i respect about
these politically correct
whiners is that the one thing they're
very creative just like the q and on
conspiracy theorists actually
very they're creative as well and i
respect that uh so very creative and
finding you
find something as not as innocuous as a
child
next to a car and you find
multiple reasons to be offended by it uh
there's something
that's that's an actual skill i don't
think it's a skill that really
will do you much good in life and
certainly it's harmful to society but
it's a skill all the same
let's go to our daily cancellation
before we do
i want to tell you about the most
exclusive membership tier over the daily
wire which is all access all access
memberships
features behind the scenes access to
live streams and discussions with your
podcast host myself included
as well as early or sometimes exclusive
access to new daily wired products as
part of that we have launched our new
limited count collectors edition
baseball bat in collaboration with
pillbox bat company
only 100 bats are being made and they're
all going to be engraved with the
individual number in the order one
through 100. so you want to get these
now
this is the crazy bad part okay these
bats were only offered
to our all-access members and they were
sold out
in two days so if you don't want to miss
out on exclusive products and offers you
should really join
all access at the daily wire so i lied i
just said a second ago you want to go
now to get back it's too late
you missed out if you didn't do it you
missed out what is wrong with you this
is why you have to listen to what i'm
trying to tell you
um you also get exclusive access to live
online discussions with our hosts
writers and special guests along with
joining all access live which is our
exclusive live stream q as
um you can still get all of that you
didn't miss out on that so you missed
out on the on the bad thing
you won't miss out on this go to
dailywire.com
walsh coupon code access to get 20
off your membership okay
today i'm going to cancel ryan reynolds
um and in some ways
i hate to do it to be honest because
prior to his cancellation
he probably would have been considered
one of the last universally
liked and likable celebrities and
there's not a lot of them left we've got
regis
well he and he just died so we lost him
alex trebek is battling cancer
um who else is there besides them there
was probably a time when you would have
said i don't know will smith but then he
went off on the scientologist deep end
so
he's out the rock maybe but he he's been
canceled a few times recently i don't
remember why but i know he has been
um you know tom hanks has gotten too
political who else is there
denzel i guess keanu reeves betty white
a lot of people like
is that it are we down to them
uh well reynolds is off the list now
unfortunately cancelled because of this
reynolds has apologized
because he got married to blake lively
at a former slave plantation eight years
ago
speaking to uh fast company this is what
reynolds says as
as he groveled and wept presumably he
said it's something we'll always be
deeply and unreservedly sorry for
it's impossible to reconcile we saw at
the time what we saw at the time was a
wedding venue on pinterest
what we saw after was a place built upon
devastating tragedy
years ago we got married again at home
but shame works in weird ways a giant
effing mistake like that
can either cause you to shut down or it
can reframe things and move you into
action
if it doesn't if it doesn't it doesn't
mean you won't f
up again but re-patterning and
challenging lifelong social conditioning
is a job that doesn't end okay first of
all he deserves to be cancelled just for
using the word re-patterning
that's definitely not a real world word
but it's exactly
the kind of jargon that i'm sure
therapists in hollywood use all the time
re-patterning second um
he's canceled of course because this is
a ridiculous reason to apology the place
he got married is called boone hall
in south carolina you could take a look
at some of the pictures here
if you're wondering why somebody would
get married here well
this is it it's just a beautiful spot
for a wedding that's all
that's why you get married there that
that's the whole reason despite its ugly
history it is now a quite beautiful
place
and that would be a quite logical reason
for a person to
get married there there's no reason for
an apology so what exactly is the
thought process here
you can't get married at a place where
bad things happened 150 years ago
and is it just slavery what if other
kinds of bad stuff happened
what if you're getting married in an old
mansion that's now a wedding venue but
it used to be owned by a rich guy who
beat his wife
can you get married there how far does
this go
and how much research are you expected
to do into the history of a place
before choosing it as a wedding venue
how far back do you need to go
and is it just weddings can you can you
live in a place where bad stuff happened
i've lived in some very old houses uh in
you know
in my life some going back nearly to
slavery times
was i supposed to check to see if slaves
were once kept in that house
and why what what is the reason for that
is the land cursed is this some kind of
superstition where there's some kind of
residual evil
left over and lurking um
if you're not superstitious and and you
don't believe that a per a place can be
cursed because of events that occurred
there a long time ago
then what is the issue it's just a place
it was used once for one thing which was
evil
now it's used for something else which
is good
i don't see the problem by the way if
we're ruling out all
places where there were one slaves
that pretty much means we're all going
to have to live work
and get married in antarctica that's
that's that kind of is all we've got
left left maybe
some spots like in the middle of the
desert in australia
maybe there um maybe the top of of mount
everest
and certainly anywhere in the ocean you
know if you want to just float out into
the middle of the ocean
make sure you're not on an old route
where slave ships used to sail but other
than that
you know um and you don't want to stop
it on any on any islands unless they're
uninhabited so
i guess there are a few options i i
guess i'm not being totally fair here
there are a few places
you've got antarctica mount everest
middle of the ocean
deserted islands and deserts that's five
places
not too bad and antarctica i guess could
be a lovely place for a wedding
might be a little cold for the doing the
wedding the the photo shoot and all that
but
yeah that's completely reasonable isn't
it nothing wrong with that
no there is something wrong with it and
uh to apologize for that
is cowardly and ridiculous and uh
many other things so ryan reynolds
unfortunately is
canceled for that and it goes without
saying everybody that was actually
offended by this
the people that precipitated this
apology are also
cancelled and we'll leave it there for
today thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening
godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio was mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
2020.
democrats refuse to condemn antifa the
revolutionary communist party endorses
joe biden
and even nbc news admits the mail-in
ballots
don't work check it out on the michael
knowles show